I want to start by introducing Sal he
really needs no introduction
particularly for a group that's this
passionate about education but as you
all know in de is about transformation
and we love to be able to welcome folks
who I think are illustrative of true
transformation and Sal is absolutely an
example of that within the realm of
Education which is something all of us
here are so passionate about so for
those that don't know I've been
interested in education reform and I may
have to amend that I love the title of
your TED talk which is reinvention
reinventing education because I think at
this point we need reinvention I don't
think reform is going to get it done and
I may have borrowed that line from Sal
but I've been interested in in education
reform and reinvention really since back
graduating high school and at the time
was thinking about the best way to make
a difference and thought about going
into teaching thought about
administration thought about getting
involved in public education in some
regard and the other alternative was
going into business and people
oftentimes say well how can you go into
business and make a difference in terms
of Education and the belief the thesis
was amass enough influence and resource
where I'd ultimately have the chance to
do that and long story short being in
business led to meeting an extraordinary
guy named Charles best who's the founder
and CEO donorschoose.org which is a
philanthropic marketplace for teachers
very close to my heart and being in
business brought me to Ted this year and
I had the extraordinary privilege to see
Sal Kahn the founder of the Khan Academy
give a TED talk that literally brought
the house down so for all the talks I
was in attendance for and there were
some wonderful talks this this talk that
Sal gave literally lit the place up
people were vibrating with energy on
what was possible because I think there
was a lot of people in the audience that
day who know how challenging it's going
to be to make a difference in terms of
education for those of you in the
audience who have committed some of your
time and energy you know that's the case
and the reason I wanted Sal to be here
today was because to a large extent
and this may be a big statement I think
he may have cracked the code
I think he may have singularly cracked
the code on how we can improve education
so long story short I think you all know
by now but Sal was in the hedge fund
business and was asked to help out it
was your cousin's cousin's your cousin's
with some math questions they had so did
a YouTube video and they raved about it
and he'll tell you a little bit more
about the feedback he got that that was
the impetus to do more and of course
fast forward today he's got over twenty
two hundred twelve minute videos from
everything algebra to American history
and and it's helping people learn in
ways that were really unimaginable
before the web came along and it's gone
way beyond that so there's a back-end
system that he and his team have put
together that for lack of a better term
I'd say has created a true adaptive
learning platform that's going to scale
and we're going to talk a little bit
about that and if he doesn't mention it
one of my favorite Q&A parts of the
entire TED conference was an exchange
between Bill Gates and Sal so with that
how about a huge round of applause for
Sal Khan welcoming to him to LinkedIn
and Sal I'm gonna ask him a few
questions just to get started and and
he'll talk a little bit but we'd really
love for this to be a brainstorming
session I think we've got a lot of
incredible talent in the audience we're
gonna be recording this so potentially
we can inspire some folks we're gonna
see this remotely at some point and
maybe they can get involved too so let's
let's start with the beginning I know
most people here saw the video but just
talk a little bit about how Khan Academy
came to be yeah it was literally as you
mentioned and I'm sure some of y'all
know I was uh I was an analyst at a
hedge fund in Boston in 2000 this is
2004 fall 2004 and my cousin and her
family her two younger brothers and her
my aunt and uncle came and visited me in
Boston right after our wedding our
wedding was in New Jersey and then we
they came up to just to kind of tour the
sites and and actually while we were
touring Boston it was a 4th of July
weekend and I remember while we're
waiting for the fireworks to start over
the Charles I would kind of give him
like my battery of brain teasers that I
use just as kind of a time killer I'm
sure probably all using this interview
and whatnot and they're very good
and and and and I remember like Nadia
was who's 12 at the time was super
engaged you know most people when you
give them brain teasers like this my
aunt my uncle everyone else are like
what's the answer or but nice like no
don't tell me the answer and she would
like walk and these are like hard you
know CSE logic problems you know hundred
people who can't see I mean there's all
sorts of crazy thing and and I was
really impressed and and and so the next
day we were touring MIT and in front of
whole family's in you Nadia you should
think about MIT I saw you have thought
you've got some skills and yes she kind
of you know didn't pay well and her aunt
her Maya her mother gave my uncle kind
of this weird look when I said that and
I didn't make much of it and then the
next morning Nazareth auntie who's
Nadia's mom told me you know that's
really nice what you said about Nadia
yesterday but she's actually being
tracked into a slower not even like the
regular algebra track I was like that's
impossible you know what I saw what she
did last night or two nights ago and you
know we share a certain amount of DNA
you know there there's this is so so
literally when Nadia woke up I said hey
Nadia I don't believe this placement
exam what was the problem she said it
was units I was like two nights ago you
were tackling stuff that's a million
times harder than units what do you say
when you go back to New Orleans we get
on Yahoo doodle and speakerphone and you
know if you're willing to do a little
bit extra work I'm willing to spend half
an hour and evening with you and and she
and she was up for it so that was kind
of the genesis so you referred during
your TED talk to what made it so
effective
half jokingly that they they liked you
better in video than they didn't know
hopeful non joking in all seriousness
talk a little bit about the magic of
what you did and the efficacy and how
you built on it from there yeah you know
so it all started you know right where I
left off I started tutoring Nadia kind
of life but remotely then I started
tutoring her brothers and the whole time
I just had kind of a doodle note board
and speakerphone so she only heard me
she didn't see me and she we just saw
the same thing that each of us were
writing and so fast forward about two
years so now we're going into November 2
six it was I was having trouble scaling
and you know the first time you give a
lecture on the greatest common divisor
it's kind of fun the 20th time it kind
of sucks so so I you know how do I do
this and is actually a buddy that
recommended I put it up on YouTube and I
which I was very dismissive of at first
I was like this for dogs on skateboards
it's not for serious mathematics but
when I got over the idea that you know
it wasn't my idea I had decided to give
it a shot and it was interesting cuz I
literally I was like okay how do I do
this I don't have a video camera should
I go get one I was like no because that
would cost money and and and said well
you know when would nadia we just had
this green going so there must be some
type of software that captures a screen
i didn't even know their word of like
screen capture software existed so I did
a web search I found some freeware that
did it and I said well I need a an art
program I'd already used Microsoft Paint
for like the first five hundred videos
yeah and just started doing it and when
I put those first videos up the first
collection of videos like 20 or 30
videos my cousin's literally did tell me
that they preferred me on YouTube and in
person and but but I think well I think
there's a lot of things and since then
I've heard a lot of feedback one is just
the form factor this is true of any
on-demand video you can pause you can
repeat you can review stuff that you
might have or maybe you should have
learned last week or last year or a
couple of years ago you don't have to
feel embarrassed you can do it when
you're ready for it you can go ahead you
don't have to it's not a
one-size-fits-all and but that's true of
all on-demand video and and I wanna make
Khan Academy is not the first on-demand
video MIT OpenCourseWare I started doing
this in 2001 I'm sure there's people who
did before that but I think the feedback
I get over and over again from people is
that they appreciate how conversational
it is and and and to some degree that's
not that wasn't by design it was
literally like I didn't care because it
was for my cousin's they're not paying
me so I said let me just make some
videos for them and there's literally an
early video where I you know I answer a
telemarketer called during the video and
I don't I don't edit it out like it's
just there I'm like I'm not interested
in DISH Network please stop bothering me
and I you know I
so exactly how to say how to say how to
say no to obnoxious telemarketers
yeah so people who enjoy the
conversational nature they like you know
early on because these are for my
cousin's I didn't have a script I didn't
have a lesson plan even I mean some of
those early videos actually I kind of
cringe at him now cuz I'm like hmmm what
should I talk about now and I just kind
of like do it let's talk about this and
then but people really like that that
the idea that look I'm expressing
exactly what's going on in my brain
right now
I'm not it's not some thing that's made
by some bureaucracy to meet some state
standard and and you know and one group
of people write a script with some
computer graphics and then another group
of people just read the script while you
know the computer graphics happen so
they like the organic nature a lot of
people you know once again that form
factor that kind of kind of our brand
now it it it you know I did it because I
didn't want to have a video camera but
people say look it actually feels
intimate it actually feels like you and
I are sitting next to each other and and
and looking through the concept together
or even you know this is kind of crazy
I've gotten letters from people who said
not not only does it feel like I'm next
to you it feels like you're in my brain
and and when they go like you know
normally on an everyday basis when they
go and think they think in their own
voice but as soon as they get to like a
math test all of a sudden they say well
now let's see what the next and they
hear me it's uh yeah so you know it's a
bunch of any of the other thing is I had
to be limited to ten minutes I guess
that was another Khan Academy innovation
but once again you know YouTube's
limited to ten minutes so I had to do it
and that was really good discipline and
and now I've gotten tons of feedback and
I've actually dug up research that shows
you know people actually can't pay
attention in any reasonable way for more
than 10 to 18 minutes and after they do
they don't out for like five minutes and
then after zoning out for five minutes
they realized they were zoning out they
said oh my god let me pay attention and
then they can only Zone in for like nine
minutes and then that and then they zone
out for like nine minutes and it gets
the zoning out gets worse and the zoning
in gets worse as you go through election
the only reason why we have 60 minute
lectures is because of logistics so yeah
all of all of these things have been
kind of an organic process and I think
our trick is to not lose any of that
that
kind of a kind of a very grounded
approach that we started off with one of
the most revelatory things you mentioned
in the TED talk I think is directly akin
to this notion of interactivity but you
put some some real you know data behind
it some anecdotes behind it and that is
kids who would otherwise be left behind
in school because they're not keeping
pace with the class in terms of the
fundamental building blocks when allowed
to learn on their own through your tools
once they got through that fundamental
building block they then got ahead in
the next block
yeah so could you talk a little bit
about that because that's a big deal
yeah and what we're seeing it well
there's there's a couple of trains of
thought there we first saw it in a
summer camp that we tried out the
primitive version of Khan Academy with
and literally six weeks into the camp I
was just curious and I literally just a
database query like who was more than
one standard deviation behind you know
four days into the camp and now is more
than one standard deviation above above
the class average at the end of the camp
and there was this one girl I won't
mention the name for private but but I I
talked her later and it literally she
just had to get positive and negative
numbers adding and subtracting them out
of the way and after she did that she
just raced ahead and then we started
looking for it more and more and but
there's other things we found not only
that which is a big deal the kid that
otherwise would have been tracked as a
slow student is now showing that if they
just have the chance to really digest
the information properly and if you
think about that's actually a property
of someone who's probably an eighth ly
gifted is someone who really wants to
digest something properly not just
understand the mechanics and probably
some of those people are being left
behind right now
and so you allows them to race ahead but
the other interesting thing we see this
in Los Altos is there some classically
kind of Rockstar students you know the
ones that are always traded they're
really like competitive and they're when
you when you force them to start at the
beginning from the most basic concepts
even some of them start to stumble at
things that they really should have
learned in third or fourth grade and
what they've probably done since then is
just they've been very good pretending
around their deficiencies or getting
around them and so almost everyone has
these gaps and you know at that summer
that same summer program where that
first student was that I mean one thing
we saw over and over again there was
there was actually two groups one was
that this was seventh graders in one
group the teacher said well you know
this would be
to make my seventh grader started one
plus one equals two so we started all of
them at like sixth grade math and then
the other group we're like yeah let's
just talk them off at one plus one
equals two and we saw the group that
start that didn't have the chance to
kind of remediate they just hit a wall
at some point they like just couldn't
progress it's or some subset of them
couldn't progress at some point while
the group that started one plus one
equals to one it was surprising how many
really basic weaknesses some of these
seventh graders had like literally
adding two-digit numbers you know
knowing how to regroup or carry or
things like this but once they got
through that it says a group they way
outperformed the other group almost as
you know even their worst performers
were better than the best performers the
other group which kind of you know is
the narrative that I think we've been
observing that no matter what you do you
get the best algebra teacher in the room
you have an innately gifted kid no
matter how hard the kid works if that
kid has trouble with third grade math
there's really no way that you can do it
in a standard education model
speaking of standard education models
talk a little bit about the the software
platform you guys have been developing
the success you've had in terms of
working with Los Altos the school
district and the impact that the videos
plus the software in the classroom is
having on classroom dynamics yeah you
know it so the software I think that if
you saw the TED talk you kind of know
what it is but it's actually stuff that
I started working on before even the
first video I you know a few months into
working with Nadia and her brothers I
said I would point them to random
websites I was like hey there's a site
that has a couple of cool problems won't
you work on those or here's another site
and you know the next morning I'd have
no information on what they did I didn't
kind of believe them that they said they
did the problem or how many they got
right or wrong so I started writing this
little JavaScript problem generator for
each and I was really just trying to
make sure that they had the core skill
down that they really just understood
the core skill and I put a little
database behind it so I could see when
do they do the problem did they use the
hints and whatever else and and then
over time had a bunch of these modules
and I got tired of assigning oh now you
ready for this module so I said hey if
you get ten in a row and this model it
will automatically assign you to the
next and that's where that the whole
knowledge tree if you saw the TED talk
kind of came about it was originally
something for me it was a tool for
myself to understand all the modules I
had built and the dependencies and then
I said well it would be cool
to see it and once again my cousin's
love that because it's like Legend of
Zelda all of a sudden they could see hey
I could get over there and and all the
rest and you know you fast forward the
summer camp started using it and it over
even there we said hey every kid can now
work at their own pace the tools the
videos are there and now the teacher can
just intervene when someone's stuck and
and then you fast forward to November of
2010 most Altos School Board literally
just you know met with myself and
chanson who is our president and said
you know we've heard great things about
what you're doing we want to learn more
about it and what would you do if you
had just whatever you wanted to do with
the math classroom and we said we'd have
every student work at their own pace the
role of the teacher they won't have to
lecture they went up to grade papers
they I don't want to say just but they
will walk into a room or and they'll get
a dashboard and the dashboard will tell
them where every student is working
who's stuck on what if they if they want
to dive deeper they can press you know a
couple of clicks and they can see
exactly what a student's been working
out and really diagnose what's probably
wrong with the student and then use that
information to either do a very focused
intervention themselves or get some of
their some of the students peers to do
an intervention it what it does is it
just a couple things one is not everyone
can work at their own pace the teachers
time is fully leveraged I mean it's in
its focus and there really just is
narrowing in on exactly what the weak
points where the students are and and
and and then the third thing is might
probably not obvious from the TED talk
and if if we've had critics it's in this
third area it's that okay
yeah Khan Academy the videos and that's
probably really good for basic skills
and you know even the videos it's good
for conceptual development but what
about project-based learning you know
there's this whole school of thought of
constructivist learning and and it's
always there's be like these math wars
there's always been like this argument
between kind of like you know like the
tiger mom school of learning and like
the constructivist Seymour Papert learn
you know play with Legos enough and
eventually you'll know calculus and and
and but it's been like a war right and
and what we're saying is and and when
people the first time they see Khan
Academy they think we are the tiger mom
version because it's like core skills
its lecture I mean we think our lectures
I mean I think the other thing that
really differentiates our lecturers over
others and this was actually surprised
for me is I made my lectures geared
towards someone like myself when I was
12 years old or 13
like I wanted the rationale I wanted a
conceptual development and I wanted my
cousin's to have that I wanted them to
be kind of you know really innately
understand math I didn't think early on
that that would be popular I thought
that most students would want the
formulas more students wouldn't want to
think about the intuition and the
surprising thing is over and over again
we get feedback from the students you
wouldn't normally associate with
students liking math saying I'm angry
that my teacher did not introduce the
intuition now it's easy so over and over
again we get that but what were you know
in this kind of debate between the the
you know what's derisive we called the
drill and kill and then the
constructivist what we're saying is like
no it's not an either/or proposition now
what's happening in those Los Altos
classrooms are so much of the blocking
and tackling is being taken off one from
the class time and from the teacher
shoulders that the teacher not only can
dive in and do very focused and
meaningful interventions but all of this
class time is freed up to do these
investigations to do these projects and
you know I'll challenge any classroom
out there to see if they can do more
project-based learning and
investigations than these little South
those classes are doing and I would
challenge any classroom out there to see
if they can do a more core skills
development than these little South
those classes are doing and they're
doing it's kind of the best of both
worlds so one of my favorite parts of
your talk that I alluded to earlier was
the during Q&A with Bill Gates at one
point everything that Sal talks about
sounds so extraordinary it sounds like
vision you know how could it possibly be
real how could we get so much good from
one guy a small team a non-profit and at
one point bill said so what would it
take to scale this to every classroom in
the country how long would that take and
your response was yeah we technically
I'm giving a little asterisks now by uh
no I mean it can be adopted tomorrow by
or you know now by every classroom and
it's it's self-service that the
dashboards everything if a teacher goes
you know the realistic answer is there
has to be some type of deployment but
there's no reason why it doesn't there's
no fundamental barrier for being used
tomorrow by every classroom in the world
so I think that's a great jumping-off
point to open it up into the group here
and we just want to do a little
brainstorming today so I was very
interested in your thoughts and I'd love
to know
this group of people how LinkedIn how
some of the folks who ultimately may be
viewing this can get involved what what
help do you need how can we start to
dramatically increase the footprint just
any questions or comments yeah please I
I didn't grow up here and I just saw
your TED talk a few days ago and after
that I also saw on the TED talk that Ken
Robinson gave about schools I'm killing
creativity yeah what are your thoughts
about that and how does it influenced
what kind of kata me is doing and what
it's planning to do yeah so yeah I mean
I think that the kid arms talks awesome
and and some people view our talks as
you know very aligned and it's kind of
some people will have view that somehow
they're not aligned and my point is kind
of going back to that what's going on a
little stossel's classrooms is that
right now so much time is focused on
kind of the mandated curriculum from the
state and so much time is focused on
kind of making sure that the worst don't
do bad that your there's no time for
real creative work in fact you know even
I'd say even 95% of people in classes
right now that claim to do project-based
learning or claimed to do creative
things in the classroom it's not
creative
it's cookbook and they you know they do
it looks good when someone we're
studying you know how we can send a
satellite to the moon or something but
they're not they're just it's some type
of cookbook thing with with words and in
the right way what we think and what I
hope kind of gotta be enables and and
you know we'd like to pilot this in more
and more schools is it can enable a
whole set of really fundamentally
creative things and some of that will
probably be beyond our platform actually
Jonathan who actually used to be a link
to employee and I used to for two
summers we did a summer camp where we
kind of view this as our R&D for like
what is the future of you know of real
learning so you have this Khan Academy
the videos you can get a lot there but
but if you really wanted people to learn
stuff and we did stuff with kids and
this is stuff like we might even
internalized into the software where I
mean it was pretty fun I mean there's
all the games I wanted to play with my
friends at my birthday party but no one
else wanted to and so we literally we
would have six
kids playing risk and and we would have
the other 24 kids they would each get a
colored piece of cardboard that says if
you're holding the state if you're
holding red at three o'clock which is
three hours from when we started that
colored piece of cardboard would be
worth the number of armies that Red Army
has at three o'clock and the same thing
for yellow and green and solar and we
gave them like five hundred dollars in
monopoly money each so they all started
with one of these and then we started
the risk and then we told the rest of
the 24 trade trade the actual things and
and it was fascinating we we saw like
fifth graders start making models
there's one fifth grader who started
doing naked shorting without knowing
what naked I mean he would literally
promised some he would sell something to
someone and say wait up but I'll I'll
give you the actual security later
yeah for those that don't know the final
derivative world that had nothing to do
with the clothing that that's hairy yes
no there was a little bit of that too no
no no no we would get the summer camp
would be shut down I think if that was
happening the no you know and it was
fastly one kid came up to me and he said
how you know he figured out that like
right after someone's turn and risk like
their security like went up because you
know we've all played a risk it looks
like that person is about to take over
the world but risk has these like huge
swings and so he would always so he
didn't even look at the board
he just shorted whoever's turn it was
and he ended up winning the whole game
because he just take took it and so you
and so you had this and then we played
another time where was the more of a
determinant where it was we played a
variation called paranoia risk where
there's only one winner
as soon as what everyone is trying to
eliminate one person from the board as
soon as one that one person is limited
from the board the person who's trying
to eliminate them wins and so now it we
said whoever if you're holding the color
of the winner that's worth 100 and
everyone else is worth zero and so now
it's a pure probability that security
should trade if it's trading at $65
that's saying you're you're saying
there's a 65% chance I didn't tell him
this ahead of time it was amazing how
many times the security started selling
like 150 or like to hunt there was like
serious bubble mentality going on and
then like we but anyway I'm going on I
could talk for hours about this but but
but but but then we play Settlers of
Catan one time with separate board games
then
second time around we let them trade
across countries we said hey how come we
weren't more we actually had like a
pariah state that couldn't trade and we
compared the development to the ones
that trait well anyway you you get the
general idea there's a lot of stuff that
can be done if class time is freed up
it's really deep that gives people
understanding I mean at one in one round
of the the risk I was the market maker
and these students trying to find
financial with a bid ask what a market
maker is what is the secondary market
versus apartment all of this stuff I
mean it might be relevant to you guys
very soon I don't know but yeah so so my
vision to answer your question my vision
is more of that without giving up the
stuff that kids need to really prove to
the world on the SATs the AP test that
they're that they know those core skills
as well sometimes people ask the
question what happens if some of our
best and brightest rather than go into
the financial world and hedge fund trade
and they were to go into areas like
education you know that's part of what
happens you get this kind of brilliant
supply in the right there could be a
good sequel to that where there's a guy
who's I won't name any names but he's a
he's a quant at a very prominent hedge
fund and he went well pretty much he
left that fund and and I think he's
being paid not to work in the industry
now because he knows too much and so
yeah he might be our analytics guy if we
things work out but yeah yeah so one of
my all-time favorite books is Neal
Stephenson's the diamond age and in it
he's got the young ladies Illustrated
primer and this rich guy builds this
book so his granddaughter can have this
tremendous education and one of the
aspects of it is is that all the content
and the learning materials are in there
but there are these Raptors who are
people who are tracking and watching as
they move through the book they actually
have a dashboard with metrics and those
and I'm thinking about our social
network and your materials whether it's
ebooks or videos and wondering if we
could create like con Raptors who would
be indexed to either their videos or the
materials and there would be people who
were certified and volunteered so that
the kid at any point where they're
stumbling can maybe hit a button get it
I am start to start to engage for that
community to get that kind of
personalized stuff worldwide ya know
that's I mean that's exactly we have to
figure out the details of how we
implement that but that's kind of our
next level because you know the first
level is videos the second level are
kind of these exercises and dashboard
the next levels the community we're
pushing 2 million unique users
a month and that's enough is you know
that's a critical mass that's growing
and so there's a couple things you know
one is just a model of volunteerism peer
to peer hey I'm at my desk I have an
hour free
I would like to tutor someone we could
facilitate that and you'll have you'll
have the same data as a teacher and we
could pair up people appropriately based
on what they know and what they don't
know and get the kids tutoring so it's
either that model or we're we're
thinking of having some kind of a
perpetual office hours so volunteers can
say hey I'll be free at this time you
know I'm in Malaysia and I'll be free
from 2:00 to 3:00 p.m. and I know these
set of topics and so if we get a
critical mass and you actually don't
need that many people but if you get
enough people you could have that
exactly what you said as soon as you're
stuck it's not even something has to be
scheduled as soon as usually you're
stuck you say I need help and it
immediately pointed points you so I'm
actually on I'm on page 85 of diamond
date right now so I haven't gotten to
the Raptor part but oh is it is it yeah
yeah but we're clearly reading the same
books but yes that's that's where we we
actually you know it's funny each layer
we kind of think is that's actually
going to be the big play not what we've
already done so would love to throw it
out there is a hack day challenge for
those of you in the room or watching it
would be pretty cool to do something
very similar and I had a similar idea
based on originally hearing you speak
you know with a hundred million members
professionals with the the right kind of
skills and backgrounds one of the things
that was most exciting to me was that
anyone can come online to lend a hand
and help mentor and answer questions so
I think would be a very cool hack to
figure out a way to do exactly what
christina was just suggesting click a
button and we could pair up the right
kids with the right mentors from among
our professional membership the other
idea that's probably a little more
in-depth than a hack is to start to
leverage everything you've done for the
kids for vocational training yeah
because one of the things that I think
we all hear increasingly is that it's
not that there's not jobs available at
times or in certain geographies there
are jobs available it's just the people
don't have the skills to take advantage
of them so if we could somehow
in some of the the back end and add
vocational training modules and then
again partner up the people that need to
learn with the professional membership
we could really do some good yeah no no
absolutely I know I think there's yeah
especially with the yeah I mean it's a
way to kind of donate your time there
could even be some badging that
transcends you know what y'all are doing
and what we're doing I mean it becomes
part of like hey I'm a proud volunteer
or even your badges hey I know I'm it's
funny because we've thought about doing
Facebook integration and it's on our
pipeline and even before we've done it
we have students who are copying and
pasting their badges they get on Khan
Academy and like kind of you know
bootstrapping the integration for words
they're so proud of it
so yeah something like that and like the
volunteer batch could be a pretty
powerful kind of mark of whatever yeah
so call to action there anyone
interested in in the next I'm also
developing modules developing modules is
actually a very easy thing to contribute
if anyone's interested if like hey I
have an expertise in probability and it
doesn't look like there's a module that
really kind of teaches and quizzes that
aspect that's you know we actually do
that as part of our interview process
for our developers and it takes them you
know if it takes it more than a day
we're like what we're not hiring them
yeah what's the best way for folks
watching who would like to contribute a
module what's the best way for them to
do you know right now it's you can
actually go you can there's a on our
page it says contribute and there's a
way you can go to our kind of our
software wiki and you can kind of how'd
you check out the code how do you see
where although you know there's even
specks out there for unbuilt modules if
you don't have an idea of what to build
and then they're all in JavaScript
they're pretty straightforward that kind
of the thinking about the learning is
harder than probably the programming
okay thanks for being here first of all
my question is I've got two kids and
what I've learned in my experience with
them is they have completely different
ways of learning you know I'm
specifically my son has dyslexia so for
him he's had to put a lot of energy into
you know doing well in school and so on
I wonder how the program you know
accommodates kids who have kind of
learning challenges disabilities and so
on well yeah and this is again another
surprising thing that it wasn't by
design you know when I started it I
viewed it
for my cousin's it may be catered or
someone like myself or probably a lot of
y'all when y'all were 12 or 13 years old
but some of the biggest feedback we get
are from parents and students with
learning disabilities dyslexia people
ADHD actually some autistic parents of
autistic students loved it and what it
is it's you know dyslexia probably the
mate
well one is the videos are very it's not
just one just and I've been told this by
dyslexics that just the fact that I'm
writing it out it's not just printed
text it just pops up is a big deal the
fact that I'm talking while I'm doing it
it kind of helps integrate everything
and that's the same thing for people
with ADHD the fact that I'm using these
different colors for the different
concepts and I think the biggest thing
and once again this goes to the form
factor is that it's it's self-paced I
mean I think a lot of you know a
dyslexic student their stress and as
soon as you're stressed you can't learn
I mean that's that's the thing that most
is there's a stress if you're taking you
half a second longer to process
something and but you have this kind of
assembly line like move along at the
same pace that's gonna leave your son
behind and now there's there's none of
that stress you can take as much time as
he needs to digest the concept so yeah I
think it's it's it's it's weird I mean I
don't want to seem like this is a
cure-all for everyone but we didn't
design it but it the gifted students
loved it the the students who are
falling behind loved it the adult
learners so it is one of those things if
you just give people a chance to learn
you don't talk down to them you respect
their intelligence you you know you
don't just teach them formulas and they
can and and you give them you know
instant feedback it's amazing it kind of
works for everybody great thank you so
rude in all of this is a product that
has proven to be incredibly effective
and you mentioned earlier YouTube
originally had limitations on the
duration of the video and and that
certainly contributed to the form factor
but I'm assuming over time there's been
a lot of iteration yeah from a product
development perspective could you shed a
little light on the approach that you've
taken because you're doing something
very right obviously and I think oh yeah
no I mean it's it's I've learned now
that there are words to describe our
process you know lead and agile and all
of this kind of stuff but it's it is
literally just you know put stuff out
there and see what happens it's you know
well there's that that's the kind of
and I think in terms of the actual thing
that goes out there I mean it's amazing
how much money and resources have been
wasted on trying to make educational
materials that look polished that look
like this and as soon as you watch them
you disengage and I think it's this
focus on the end user and nothing else
and not trying to pretend you know when
when I started and now as an
organization we never want to fake that
that were good quality right and
probably you know and so a lot of these
attempts to really polish up things are
too fake that it's good quality because
to the to the maybe the buyer who's not
the user the buyer might superficially
look at something say oh there's
computer graphics that must be good
quality but I think the the big takeaway
from the Khan Academy if something is
really going to take on it really just
has to purely cater to the user and even
if it is crappy and not the most
professional thing it'll still resonate
and in terms of the process you know I'm
now getting approached by a lot of you
know we want I want other people other
than myself to teach and I've been
approached by some medical schools and
others and you know we want to do
something like this in our program and I
sat through some of those meetings and
they go on it you know and and we have
to talk to this department so now my
policy is when anyone and you know wants
to say hey we think we have some people
who might be able to make videos we want
to use them
I say no preliminary meetings just come
to my office I'll go take a walk and
make the videos I'll show you how to do
it and they just want them to start
making videos and like wait wait we
haven't planned as like no they they
teach these classes just tell them to
come make a ten minute video and then
we'll talk about whether you know how we
can improve them and you know it kind of
scares these people though the fact that
they might actually produce something
but uh but yeah I think that's the take
you know and even in our organization
we're kind of since were such a small
organization were like six people going
on a tour 7x7 people now we're very
bandwidth constrained and so now we're
trying to like you know I tell chanson
who is our president if me and him are
in the same meeting at the same time
there's something wrong with our process
we force people to go on walks for
meetings so that it's a fixed I mean I
don't it you know I all mean it's
changed things out here okay yeah we do
that I mean a lot of the a lot of the
yeah I mean it's funny it's like an
important meeting I said I
El Camino and back if it's kind of a
shady meeting I'm going to the train
stopping back hopefully now if y'all
wanted me to say let's just go to the
Caltrain station yeah yeah yeah you kind
of know where you fit in the hierarchy
how long it will walk no but the other
thing is we actually want to eat our own
dog food which is look the reason why
we're able to scale why such a small
organization is able to you know on some
level educate 2 million kids and maybe
200 million kids eventually or whatever
is that we're using these technologies
so even you know even our board meetings
you know right now our board meetings we
spent three hours just giving an update
I'm like this is silly
like I'm just gonna make youtube videos
explaining what we've been up to the
last week you know I have the screen huh
it's a road show and they can our board
can pause and repeat it and now like
where exactly you know and and and we're
thinking of making this a practice
across the organization where everyone
we're gonna get everyone Camtasia and
everyone at the end of the week instead
of like you know writing me an email or
shot like hey this is what I've been up
to they had their computer right there
this is what I'm working on and just
just archive it and that way when we go
into meetings we're all on the same page
we know what everyone's been up to if
someone says something that's unfamiliar
I don't have to pause the meeting I can
go back and see what they're up to and I
should get a much better and actually
I've told a bunch of people this I have
a buddy who was working at another
startup and I told this idea and he
bought into it and and he told her their
CEO he's like because she she wanted him
to write a white paper about what he's
up to and and he's like oh well how
about I do a screencast because now you
know you can pause repeat it'll be me
explaining it as a human being and I can
show you and it was funny they had a lot
of like no that's silly it needs to be a
white paper and but it begs no it
doesn't it should really just be it I
mean it's it takes ten minutes to make a
ten minute video especially if it's for
just like internal consumption as
opposed to a day to write a white paper
that no one's going to read and and so
yeah that's that's what we're up to I
was just reminded of the effectiveness
of the RSA animations yeah which is very
similar in terms of mapping out and crap
yeah voiceover and you hear folks you
know a lot of people in the audience
that I'm sure they'll rave about them
yes you've seen this on motivation have
you seen
hey so thanks for being here um a few
weeks ago we watched Waiting for
Superman here at LinkedIn and was
incredibly moving and yeah and I learned
about the Khan Academy after watching
that movie here at LinkedIn and so after
spending time on your site it was pretty
obvious to me that what you have
developed can be the superheros solution
for schools they don't have resources
for kids they don't have resources to
help them learn and so I'm just
wondering if part of the Khan Academy's
chatter at charter is to get those kinds
of resources into the hands of kids
where you know they don't have computers
at home or the school systems don't have
computers is that part of the
conversation yeah absolutely so so I
mean there's a couple of things you know
one of the things and this is something
that we're very protective of as an
organization is the reason why I think
we're resonating where a lot of other
attempts governmental attempts NGO
attempts for-profit attempts have all
failed is that everyone else is trying
to kind of reform the Beast you know
they're trying to go in there and chisel
at it and you know Lobby this or that
and all the rest and the reason why I
think we've worked as we've ignored the
beast we've just kind of done our own
thing and and go straight to the student
but at the same time this was also
saying which kind of fell in our lap
proves that no this can help the Beast I
shouldn't call the beast anybody but so
so so you know what what we're doing is
we're and this wasn't our plan even a
month ago but especially the TED talk
kind of took this to the next level we
are building kind of a roll out SWAT
team and what we're gonna do over the
next six months because the other thing
we want to be careful about is not
rolling out too fast and ruining you
know we're kind of like you know the
Trader Joe's model you know we want the
community to really want us and look
okay well you gotta give us the right
space and it's all but what we want the
SWAT team over the next six to 18 months
we reached out now by about ten schools
or school districts a day who want to do
this and so we want to pick the 10 or 15
that are the most likely to be a success
and they don't have to all be affluent I
mean actually hopefully they won't won't
mainly be affluent school districts like
Los Altos we're looking for underserved
communities some charter schools some
independent schools some regular
middle-class private schools all of the
above some fancy private schools
and Andrusha going district-wide in
fourth fifth and sixth grade and los
altos as well so every if you have a
fourth or fifth or sixth grader in Los
Altos you'll start hearing me in your
you know in your house whether you like
it or not so we want to do that and once
we have that we learn more we can kind
of productize it then we're going to
explore how it can become a more massive
role and that's it and and the narrative
throughout this is we're also gonna make
it more and more self-service I mean
like that first question you would ask
it can be used in any school district
tomorrow and to some degree that's
another volunteer opportunity if your
school district isn't doing and you
think they should you guys can become
the ambassadors for it and you guys all
have the same you know if you guys go to
our website it'll be pretty obvious how
you could implement this in the
classroom and so you could be that
person that goes to the school district
say look we can do this we can go you
know the Los Altos people are awesome
about other people coming in and
observing the classrooms you know so if
it's local you'll say hey why don't we
go meet with those Los Altos people
observe their classroom and then we'll
implement it here and you guys can
Shepherd it make sure their firewall is
set up whatever so so what happens and I
think that that by itself could be a
pretty actually that might be the most
powerful way to volunteer so how do
teachers respond to it do they feel like
it's an incredible tool that helps take
their classrooms to the next level at
times do they feel threatened by it what
kind of response to you yeah I mean you
know we get like a positive selection
bias for the ones that reach out to us
are the ones that are probably using us
on some level and those those teachers
are excited more excited than I even
thought originally that they because I
think that the really skilled teachers
the reason why they went into teaching
is they wanted to form bonds with
students they wanted to they wanted to
be creative themselves and test the the
children's creativity but then when they
go into a classroom there's 30 kids all
different levels they have to do all of
us you know classroom management you
know be quiet and and and actually
that's almost more of the you know if I
had to become a teacher tomorrow in a
real classroom that's the stuff I would
have to learn because I don't know I
actually did volunteer once in college
and literally within 10 minutes all of
the kids were standing on top of the
table and I had no idea what I did wrong
like it was like this but but the
teachers want to be this liberated
person who can form bonds who can dig in
who have the data
and and and and so the teachers who kind
of see that they've loved it these Los
Altos teachers love it I spoke to all of
the Los Altos elementary school teachers
and they're pretty much I mean as far as
I could tell it seems like they're on
board
I think the resistance comes from you
know it comes from people who aren't
familiar with what we're trying to do
and they just see the headline or they
just see the eye they just get a glimpse
of kind of what it's about so
unfortunately there have been headlines
like you know will will Khan Academy is
this the solution to our education
problem I mean maybe we think it is on
some level but when people people react
they have a knee-jerk reaction to kind
of this panacea type thing and oh no
this is you know this isn't it and this
is going to be just drilling kill
learning and you know they'll say all of
that type of thing there's obviously a
lot of people on you know we try to stay
out of political debates but there's a
lot of people who view Khan Academy as
an empowering tool against things like
teachers unions or against things like
or to impart so when when teacher maybe
some of the teachers union see someone
else say oh now that Khan Academy is
here this is gonna get you guys they
immediately react against it but and you
know we try not to enter those debates
but what I will say is that no we're
empowering the teachers where it's going
to free up their time you know right now
and this is why teachers are I think so
frustrated is every time there's a new
study that comes out that shows that
schools are falling behind and we're
falling behind Senegal or whatever some
other country the reaction of
policymakers is we have to micromanage
more we have to go in there and the
belief is is that and the
micromanagement is all around the focus
of de-risking the worst teachers
de-risking the worst students on some
level and and what it does is it
completely it completely straps everyone
else in and what we're doing is not
we're liberating everyone you can cater
to everyone and to some degree you are D
risking that the teacher who might not
have and I'm not saying this is most
teachers but in any industry there's a
bell curve and there's the bottom 5% of
teachers and 5% of kids are in front of
the bottom 5% of teachers and you can do
risk them because now they have an
alternative and now that the the top 95%
of the top 50% of the top 5% of teachers
are liberated to fully express their
kind of abilities their creativity they
could think of stuff like my trading
game or even
stuff and so I would say on the whole
the ones that have watched the TED talks
the ones that have understood what we're
trying to do are pretty excited the one
other dimension is and this is happening
though Southold classroom I mean there's
literally there's 5th graders doing the
chain rule in a Los Altos classroom and
so as a teacher that can be a little
daunting you're a fifth grade teacher
you signed up to be a fifth grade
teacher and there's a kid doing calculus
in the room and but what we saw from the
one teacher when we observed it she
literally like and he was marked by the
dashboard as red like he wasn't
understanding the chain rule so she's
like I better intervene but was really
powerful was is that she went and she
said you know what I haven't seen this
since college and I kind of forgot how
to do this or what this was all about
why don't we learn it together and we
actually you know I was there observed
that the kid it immediately clicked with
the kid like he it almost felt like he
respected the teacher ten times more
because she was willing to let down her
guard as the you know the the source of
all correct answers in the world and
yeah so a teacher has to feel feel feel
comfortable actually on the same line
there was a a reporter was doing a story
and he visit one of the fifth grade
classrooms and there was one girl and
there was doing trigonometry and the
reporter sits down next to her and says
so so do you think this is fifth grade
math and then the girl goes no I think
it's sixth grade thank you thank you for
being here so I watched your TED talk
twice
well once I discovered it on LinkedIn
today by the way and it was like 9 P
violently and something like that I
watched it I was completely blown away I
called my wife I need to show you
something so we watched it together the
second time and you know like it made me
like deeply depressed and I I love you
building into it yeah so the problem
here is that you know like that you have
two aspects in the system right one is
you learn at your pace
second one your exercise collaboratively
in in the room with other kids yeah so
it needs to be implemented in a school
system and some way like you can't do
that without implementing in the school
system school systems are slow
my kid is four and a half years old I
want her to do that in two years yes I
don't live in Los Altos yeah not neither
do I so this is oh yeah I have another
interesting story to tell I don't live
in Los Altos either but yeah I also have
another interesting so and I actually I
was growing up in the third world yeah
and I made it here to the Silicon Valley
which i think is quite an achievement
for myself and now I kind of feel as if
I'm back to the third world because my
kid will not be that genius you you will
create you know like if you yes million
genius kids and like a couple of bill
and squirt as dumb as they are right not
sorry
understood including my own yeah yeah
how can we scale it fast yeah I have two
years yeah yeah yeah so I my my III I'm
actually very close to it because I
actually live about a hundred feet from
the mountain the Los Altos district
border like I live in Mountain View and
your quest to park and and like you know
the same house cost three hundred
thousand more like literally two hundred
feet away because of this discrepancy in
the school system and and and and and
and one of these fifth graders actually
goaded me on when I heard the story is
that so on that same news piece so these
kids were doing like they call it a
rocket run where they like the teacher
sets up this thing where they measure
how fast they can do something so
usually do a very simple exercise so the
they took all this footage when they
went to the classroom and these kids
something couldn't doing trigonometry
and all sorts of crazy stuff but the
footage they showed on NBC Nightly News
was these kids doing arithmetic right
and when I talk to the teacher they're
like oh they love the news piece but
they really didn't like the fact that
the footage showed them doing arithmetic
and then but but in the news piece they
said they mistakenly said that this was
a pilot in Mountain View and so one of
the kids said well at least they think
we're in Mountain View
which I had the same kind of reaction I
was like no mountain you must come back
and so I mean the simple answer is we're
trying to go as fat you know our and to
it seemed like this will work is if we
can do enough like powerful use cases
and you know the berry is going to be
disproportionately where most of these
use cases are I mean already I've been
told that little salt those people Palo
Alto Unified per ton of these are cheap
areas either but but but all of them
have started to tour them and they're
they seem interested but if you can do
these really powerful use cases around
and and and and probably the scariest
thing is when when when people all over
the country like you see that there are
kids in these ten or fifteen schools of
all different not just affluent
neighborhoods maybe it's some of them
are owners but across the board they're
learning at their own pace they're
engaged in mathematics the classroom is
fun and they're doing trigonometry or
whatever you're gonna get scared and
you're gonna really you're gonna really
rock the boat in your local school
district and you and the other parents I
mean I think the PTA is probably the
biggest strong you know that's the
strongest influence and so we're hoping
that that I mean hopefully we can
address your school district maybe it'll
be one of the fifteen but I think it
took massive change I think that's
what's going to be it's gonna be parents
having that visceral reaction that you
just had because I think that's that's
yeah that's the best way to kind of
disrupt and I have a two-year-old so
Mike I have I have about three years to
get Mountain View I'm up to speed thank
you very much so so oftentimes when
people think about hacking and ways in
which they can get involved I'm sure
they're thinking about the code the
product you were talking about modules
earlier but I think this this parent led
advocacy and kind of demand driven
approach is going to be important yeah
to accelerate things so one of the
things we may want to start thinking
about is how we create a little bit of
an I want my MTV yeah strategy or energy
where we make it incredibly simple for
parents to come together to start
requesting within their communities yeah
that would be awesome actually that'd be
super powerful yeah yeah so maybe some
folks can get together afterwards we can
do some brainstorming on that
hey so thanks a lot for coming in so in
spirit of brainstorming just wanted to
throw out possibility of LinkedIn skills
seems like a really natural connection
in here with Khan Academy because we
have people on our site who have skills
and they're highlighting the skills and
their over time they're you know there
may be available to help they met and
you may be going and you know looking at
skills wanting to learn them and that
could be a good jumping off point to
Khan Academy and the flipside you know
coming back from Khan Academy over to
LinkedIn so that just seemed like a
really natural yeah actually that would
be cool I'll take another level to that
because you know the one thing that
we've been experimenting with is how do
we get increased the teaching base
beyond me right and and it's not
actually it's not a rate limiting factor
for us where we are right now but it
would be HUGE if everyone taught
everything that they know and so if you
had a skill I mean it's it's funny the
the the first hedge fund I worked for
the performance retired it but then the
second hedge fund I worked for they were
so impressed by my videos on Finance
that I almost didn't have to interview
that they were like wow this guy clearly
knows his finance and so there could be
something very interesting with LinkedIn
I mean we could work out the details
where you teach what you know and one
that obviously has social good to it but
it's huge marketing for yourself just
cuz other a lot of people will watch
what you know and if any employer says
well does you know buddy well hey
clearly he's teaching the subject your
video account your video counted a
thousand people have watched this
exactly especially if other people
endorse it and there's some type of you
know curation going on that would be
powerful we've been thinking you know
there's Ted and then there's TEDx I
don't feel are familiar with the
difference TEDx is kind of the franchise
you can start a TEDx you know shoreline
and as long as it meets their standards
you do a conference and then you record
all the videos and then Ted will look at
some of those videos and the good ones
they'll put in on Ted calm and so we've
been thinking about doing something like
that with Khan Academy and we've
jokingly called it ex-con it was but but
and so this could be an interesting I'm
just brainstorming out loud absolutely
something like this it gels with
LinkedIn's knowing what you know showing
what you know your network being able to
appreciate that
and at the same time helping to
potentially build a very powerful
library of of really useful stuff I mean
and a lot of it could be just I mean
very hands-on you know hey I'm the
office manager this this is how I think
about ordering that I mean very basic
stuff it or it could be very
sophisticated nobody knows anybody
else's job very well exactly just
actually that's the huge corporate kind
of knowledge management difficulty and
this would be I mean yeah right now in a
lot of corporations the ability to rise
up is based on how well you can you know
market yourself but now of a sudden if
you like wow now I understand what that
person does and wow it's brilliant and
you know that person you know there's
there's all sorts of positive things
that that could be from that yeah yeah
thanks so what if we just created a tell
us what you know piece of text yeah on
the skills page so it's not you know a
status update hundred forty characters
or less it's you know ten twelve however
long the duration would be minutes and
we could give people a little space on
their profile to upload the video yeah
and use skills jumping-off point
so it's essentially highly targeted
marketing for the right people the right
expertise we could also leverage skills
obviously the module in the middle of
that page is showing some of the most
influential people within that skill
community we may want to think about
sending a mail to some of those folks
and it's all in for good so we could say
how would you like to get involved with
being the first to tell us what you know
and participate in some kind of
collaboration between the Khan Academy
and LinkedIn yeah that's awesome
it's a great idea my thing okay I sell
thanks for coming so I know your focus
is primary education but I wanted to ask
you a little bit about you know our
university system here so there's been a
lot of talk recently about kind of like
a bubble in higher education Peter Thiel
and exactly you know college costs are
ballooning as a society we replacing
more and more and more just emphasis on
credentials yes
Ivy League is the big thing everybody
wants their kids here the Ivy League if
you have any thoughts about reforming
that kind of system and will not reform
because I know reinventing reinventing
of that system specifically and maybe if
there's anything we need to change our
way of thinking as a culture so that we
can get back on track yeah yeah so and
so just give you all background so you
know so Peter Thiel founders of PayPal
he runs Clarion Capital another hedge
guy he's been pretty vocal about this
bubble in higher education he kind of
he's been good at spotting the previous
well the housing bubble that the tech
bubble and all of that is that it's a
bubble because people believe people are
willing to pay ridiculous amounts of
money in perception that it's a good
investment when it really isn't which is
what a bubble is right and that's true
the housing bubble is true that was true
of the tech bubble and so his his kind
of country you know beyond just talking
about it he his attempt at kind of
disrupting it which i think is in the
right direction but I don't think it
goes quite enough is he started this
program where he's targeting you know
the same kids who would otherwise go to
Stanford or MIT or Harvard or whatever
and say look I'll pay you a hundred
grand if you drop out of school and come
start a business and he's trying to make
it so there's something very very
desirable like a very prestigious to
have and and and we'll probably will
help your career that doesn't cost money
that you would give up that other thing
you'd give up the college degree and
this might become more desirable I think
what would really work I mean to take
his thing to the natural and you know
I've thought it out it as a kind of a
crazy idea like three or four weeks ago
and now it's getting a little less crazy
is I think would be awesome to start a
university for black of a better word in
say Mountain View and and you and and
this first university I know I don't to
make it sound elitist but it would focus
on the best and the brightest it would
focus on the same kids who are applying
to Stanford and MIT and Harvard all of
this right now and I'll take a tangent
on why I say that it because I think
that's the only way you can disrupt
because if you can so the goal here is
instead of these students paying fifty
thousand a year and going into debt they
would be paid and the reason why I say
that is if you can make the best
education have negative tuition then you
know it's like a geeky calculus analogy
by the squeeze theorem you know
literally how can anyone else justify
charging anything right if the best
education is negative tuition and so you
get you get people to come in and the
the curriculum is literally six months
at LinkedIn six months at Google they
work in they work in software
engineering they work in product
management they work in and marketing
they work in PR they work in accounting
six months at Apple six months working
for a VC firm six months developing
iPad apps or whatever and they are paid
some and some of the money goes to the
students maybe 30 grand a year and then
some of it goes to the university to set
up the environment that you should have
so it's not this purely commercial thing
so you have all of the things that we
all liked about college you have a
campus you have pretty trees to read
books under you have you have venues to
meet your future husband or wife and and
and you have a scaffold of a truly
academic material that you can do at
your own pace something like the Khan
Academy and the faculty and you have
seminars hey I'm working on a project at
LinkedIn but you know what this is gonna
require some signal processing
I don't know signal processing I go back
to the campus there are either other
students there there's Khan Academy
resources or there are mentors in the
valley who are willing to work with me
on signal processing and then I learn it
and you go through this so what's gonna
happen is these students are gonna end
up finishing not with debt they're gonna
have money saved they're gonna be way
more desirable by you know this whole
slew of companies and they're kind of
have the downside protection because
they still had a little bit of an
academic scaffold they'll do well in the
MCAT the GRE if they decide they want to
become a doctor or a lawyer they can
still they can still do that and I think
if you do that it'll be pretty hard for
Stanford to justify charging you know
and this the other thing is we could go
right out the gate because if you get
the employers involved especially these
kind of marquee employers and maybe even
the Khan Academy because we have a brand
and it's in the right place you you you
you don't face that hard the difficulty
of starting a university that no one's
ever heard of people will hear of this
university on day one right and so I
think something like that and if that's
successful then of some the tuition
inflation it becomes very hard to
justify and then you can start more and
more of these around around the country
at different levels different
specializations so I know I think like
Olin University and Boston I don't know
if you're familiar yeah yeah tried to do
something similar to that it was like
free Engineering College most of their
professors were from MIT and they kind
of did like the project exploration yes
I know some people had good results
going there I don't know if you I think
the problem with all and actually I know
them pretty well my advisor at MIT
actually ended up becoming a professor
at Olin I think the problem is is
the reason why people are paying
$200,000 right now is is to have a
signal to send to the job market that I
kick butt and even though old and I
haven't gone to Olin but I could imagine
is probably a very good education that's
not why people are spending two hundred
thousand dollars people are spending
this they want that signal I went to MIT
I went to Caltech it's the brand and so
Olin has a problem of that and and it
also has the problem with the
connections I don't know if Google maybe
Google does but I don't know if Goldman
Sachs recruits at Olin even though maybe
they should because they don't have the
they don't have they don't know what
Olin is and so I think the key thing
would have to have some type of
partnership with very marquee recruiters
because if you get if you get an
ecosystem of ten of the top-tier that
the companies everyone wants to work for
the other companies the next year of
companies are going to say wait if
Google's getting their linkedin is
getting all of this talent there we we
better get our talent there too we don't
look like we're getting you know the
scraps from you know so I think I think
it's very important to build a whole
ecosystem there and actually the big
difference would be that the projects
would be stuff that actually matters
like actual and you know in the past if
you were to if I would have recommended
this 50 years ago people would have said
oh my god but you're making people do
vocational things inside you know that's
horrible it's commercial but the reality
is the stuff that's going on in LinkedIn
right now the analytics the software
engineering the marketing the stuff
that's going on at Google it's more
intellectual than the software
engineering projects that we worked on
when we were undergrads it's more
intellectual than almost anything than
the kind of made-up projects that that a
university gives you right now
so I think if you build the holy cosign
I think Silicon Valley is the perfect
place to do it
right the one thing I've discovered
through Khan Academy's there's a lot of
people who kind of made it who are like
super smart we're kind of orbiting the
the valley just looking for someone to
mentor looking to kind of disrupt things
a little bit and so you know you could
imagine instead of instead of this
school showing off about how many Nobel
laureates they have on their faculty
they say no we have you know we have the
CEOs of this company this company these
are these are our market and either
these entrepreneurs and these people
who've done amazing things in the world
this is our faculty these are the people
you have access to as your as your
mentors I think you do something like
that I think would be pretty pretty hard
to compete with all right thanks so much
okay so these gonna be the last three
questions Stiles already stayed a little
bit extra but there have been some great
questions so yeah thank you very much
for coming so I have a question going
back to scale you know Ron has given us
a two-year deadlines quickly where do
you live by the way oh yeah yeah a very
underserved community
yeah no I think hopefully I think I
think we might be able to meet your your
your goal but oh yeah my question is
have you thought about making the Khan
Academy lectures more searchable
basically being able to reach them more
easily from other sites or partnering
with other sites or even your students
themselves have you had any experiences
with them really growing your user base
because they've shared you know their
experience with someone else and do you
think that that's a viable way to grow
more quickly than actually getting an
entire educational institution to come
on board and kind of buy into this oh
yeah well you know so this would be
clear you know and this is only we tell
our team the whole time this is kind of
roll out into schools kind of fell into
our lap and we're like why this is an
opportunity and there's no obvious
resistance oh let's do it but our number
one goal is actually that it's actually
the organic word-of-mouth kids telling
kids about it features direct to
students someone you know one-off kid or
parent trying to learn even
homeschoolers that that still is we want
Khan Academy to if you have nothing else
you're still able to get an education
but you know to ask ask your questions
about the search ability that's
something we're working on I mean it's
actually it's we I mean you know 1200
2200 videos it's this huge curation
problem we're figuring out ways to kind
of categorize it better ways to make it
more searchable we're getting
transcripts on them so that they can be
text searchable and the Google people
have told us that that's actually it's
unfortunate that if you do a text search
for algebra right now Khan Academy
videos are not they don't even come up
on the first page like all sorts of
random stuff because there's no text
that says parabola and all this type of
stuff so we're gonna work on that so it
becomes a lot more meaningfully
meaningfully searchable yeah so in terms
of making the Academy's content more
palatable to the Beast yes is there any
academic research being
going on in terms of the efficacy of the
program and yeah
so we wanted I mean we're eager to do
more like hardcore rigorous studies that
even the Los Altos I mean that you know
the I've been broadly impressed with the
whole Los Altos school system you know
from the teachers the parents all the
way up to the the superintendent I mean
they're not like somewhat they're not
people who like get enamored with an
idea and say let's just go district-wide
with it for the hell of it so so they've
actually done so with this the the to
seventh grade classes who have been
using it these were they call it algebra
readiness classes and and so these
classes are actually I guess you'd call
them they were the they were there the
students not in the medium track and so
these students they did kind of a before
and after and these kids went from like
I don't forgot the exact numbers but is
on the order I'm not exaggerating like
20 percent proficiency of out of algebra
and pre-algebra concepts to I think is
like 80 percent on average it was a
dramatic change and actually never had
these classes before so they don't know
what happened in previous years but that
was pretty powerful for them it doesn't
like instead of doing both 5th and both
seventh grade classes if you have to do
you know one fifth sits in seventh grade
class and you're not the other and the
do cohort exactly so the fifth grade
we're doing that so the fifth grade they
had a fifth grade assessment that they
do every year and so the one thing that
so that the the results came out and our
fifth grade classes despite the fact
that we worked in this actually I was
stressed about this because the other
classes were literally teaching to the
test and our classes they were doing
like this crazy stuff like I had nothing
to do with the exam and ours did at
least or better than those and so you
know the good thing is we're definitely
not damaging anything and which is
important I mean it's amazing how many
times that question is not asked so
we're definitely not doing damage and
everyone's more engaged so even on that
metric alone it seems like it makes
sense to move forward but the more
powerful thing is and everyone
recognizes this is that these kids are
doing trigonometry and algebra that's
not being measured on the fifth grade
assessment and so I'm actually gonna
administer an SAT to to to a control
fifth grade class and to this fifth
grade class and and I'm hoping to see
one thing I the fifth graders we've been
doing algebra will do much better on the
SAT but I have a suspicion they'll do
much better than many than the average
high school senior do so so I think we
do stuff like that and then we can we
can do more
these aren't rigorous ties this is
really me like administering an SAT like
it's not but but these will be kind of
the the data points that tell us that we
can do a really rigorous study and one
of the obstacles you can hit is those
people then I got a master's degree so
they could teach middle school math are
you reluctant if you don't you know
showing the money first and last comment
yeah if you make the effort to map your
particular modules to the common core
standards yes that would make it a lot
we're doing that as we speak there were
like 80 percent done and 80 percent done
mapping we have to actually had a lot
more modules the videos were a pretty
comprehensive with a mod we've got a lot
more but but that's that's we're doing
that and but it's just like a
spreadsheet right now we're going to
surface that so that you can navigate
with with the Common Core but we know to
answer the teacher question I mean it's
the other thing teachers can use this to
say I mean that's the other thing that
side effect the teachers actually using
this to learn and say and there have
been studies that show that the best
teachers actually the ones that have the
best like second grade math teachers are
the ones who know calculus just because
the kids know that they're kind of
there's more there they know what's
going on so that the teachers can use
this to to ramp up and and and and kind
of stay ahead of the curve well speaking
second grade teachers I am one so think
okay I want to say thank you to LinkedIn
for inviting me as well I'm from
Northern California I teach at a charter
school and I actually have an employee
here sending my class but I had a
question more about taking it back to
the actual implementation I Los Altos
schools are they using a one to one
ratio of computers in the classroom I
mean yes it's at the computer during
that math lecture the whole time so they
they have one-to-one although what we
found is you actually don't need
one-to-one because so much of the time
is spent doing other things that you
could probably time share the computers
you could probably do a three to one
ratio and it wouldn't and it would
probably work out just as well just
because there's some time where you're
actually are working with your peers and
you're not even using the computer but
that is a gating factor at some point
you do have to have internet
connectivity and we're thinking about
offline use cases for the developing
world but what we like to think is you
know I even you know when I went to
school in like the 80s and 90s in a
fairly middle-of-the-road
public school system in Louisiana there
were computers they just went completely
unused and I think the skepticism for
deploying more money behind computers is
just
it's like what are they doing right now
with the computers how is it actually
helping anyone and I think if you
actually give a use case for the
computers and it's actually not these
people are you know the teachers the
principal's the administrators the
parent are getting this real-time data
then I think if the question becomes how
can we operate without these computers
yes and then you know there's a there's
a narrative here too where you know at
least I think you don't need textbooks
anymore and so that's a cost savings
yeah and then implementing it then
multiple grade levels I mean would you
start I mean with the modules you were
talking about I mean I've started
working through it myself as rushing
trying to get to the calculus level as a
second grade teacher I guess but
implementing it within fourth fifth
sixth seventh eighth I mean at what
point I mean you know those kids because
I mean there's only so many modules and
if you're in school 186 days a year I
mean how are they going to keep going
through all those modules for yeah well
some of those fifth graders are almost
done with all of our modules that we
have so actually we're having we're
ramping up hiring faster that we can
stay ahead of them and you know the
funny answer is it's funny that this is
a product you know I mean if if I have
12 year old a 13 year old that did that
I would say you know I'll just take the
SAT take the GED and go work or
something like you know like you know go
explore things for a couple years and if
you want to go to college go to that's a
good problem that's a good I mean it's
funny it sounded like a crazy idea but
but someone recommended it is that we
should start schools where it isn't like
this is the tuition per month or this is
the tuition per semester it's just like
if your kid gets over 700 on the SAT you
pay us I mean right now if you go to a
private school thirty thousand a year
for 12 years is a lot of three hundred
sixty thousand dollars right and most of
them are still not getting seven hundred
on the SAT right and so you say no
however long it takes if it takes them a
week if it takes them 20 years if your
kid gets a seven hundred kid gets a
seven hundred pay us a hundred grand I
mean it was a joke we were just kind of
you know but actually something like
that actually would be good because if
the kid finished is faster it's good for
everyone
it's good for the kid it's good for the
school system it's good for a resource
allocation it's good so and you know
none of this is being taped so don't
take my that idea seriously about this
performance but actually well anyway
it's um
it's but but I think the simple answer
is it's not a problem it's an awesome
problem if that kid you know actually
the best thing to do with that kid is
the kid who's already maxed out
everything higher make him a TA like
yeah I'm just seeing the balance between
language development writing reading
their stuff and so you have a sixth
seventh eighth grader who has maxed out
yes your modules in calculus but they're
not prepared yet in my opinion to go up
the work field in terms of their writing
ability all right now this is and so
this is there's two things here one is
because these are fifth grade classes
the same teacher does teach all the
subjects correct so one these teachers
are actually they're like frustrated
with the other subjects now because they
feel like it's like Stone Age is now
they don't have this data analytic
self-paced teaching so hopefully we can
expand and build some tools into the
other subjects the other thing is is you
know we've even thought maybe we should
start one school ourselves maybe we do
it right we actually even thought about
you know doing it someplace around here
so maybe you would have an option other
than but but it's it's it's not by grade
level it's just one room classroom in
the same room you have kindergarteners
in the same room you have 18 year olds
and the stuff that you already have
maxed out you are a TA and the other
stuff you are being T aid and I think if
you do a model like that I think it's
and there's all sorts of interesting
models about teaching each other
maturity that you can only get in that
type of a framework that you you know
right now you're stuck with just your
other ten year olds and you know we've
all seen it if you if you have older
kids around you act more mature and if
you have younger kids around you act
more mature because you have
responsibilities now I think if we
explore that a little bit more we'll
have a way that we can really you know
once a kid is giving more into the
system and they're taking out pay them
station I pay pay there should be TAS
well as a teacher thank you oh yeah
thanks yeah
so speaking of thanks it's interesting
juxtaposition so at our last in day we
do this once a month where employees
have an opportunity to invest time
energy and the things they're most
inspired by and excited by and education
is a recurring theme for us reinventing
education and at the lasting day we
screened Waiting for Superman yeah and I
think a lot of people in the room today
saw it and it's hard not to way walk
away from the film feeling a bit of
despair yeah I think there is an
understanding that things need to
improve but I also think perhaps naively
prior to seeing the film a lot of folks
believe that if you live in this country
and you wanted to be educated you you
wanted to learn and do your best and be
prepared for opportunity when it came
that you could and what that movie
certainly shed a very very dark light on
was the fact that you know that's not
the case that it's come down to a
lottery and I think most folks here
learned the economics of lotteries at a
very young age and if we all believe
that the future of our country to a
large extent depends on the next
generation and their ability to be
educated we don't want to be placing a
bet on a lottery we want to be placing a
bet on people like you so as as
depressing as some of those themes were
I think you represent the exact opposite
so you represent the fact that what
could appear as completely intractable
unsolvable problems are absolutely
solvable and you and I think you
mentioned eight or nine folks you know
one of the key things we like to talk
about here is how to scale and how to
transform things and you are living
proof of what's possible when someone
with incredible vision intelligence and
energy channels that one thing looks and
sure milk it further channels that into
into something so extraordinarily
important and valuable and on behalf of
all of us so thank you for everything
you and your team are doing to reinvent
education and I know I speak for all of
us when I say we're going to do
everything within our power to help you
awesome
yeah that's excited